يواصل رئيس الوزراء البريطاني بوريس جونسون
الإصرار على أنه لم تكن هناك
قيود كوفيد تم كسرها ولم يكن
هناك حفل للموظفين عقد في 10 داونينج ستريت
في ديسمبر من العام الماضي على الرغم من
الأدلة المتزايدة التي تشير إلى أن شركة CNN
التابعة لـ ITV قد أبلغت الآن أن
الرئيس الصحفي لجونسون ألقى خطابًا
وسلم  منح جوائز وهمية لما يصل إلى 50
شخصًا في التجمع ويبدو من
الصعب جدًا على الناخبين الاعتقاد
بوجود حزب في
مقر إقامة رئيس الوزراء وأنه
لم يكن على علم به ، تظهر استطلاعات الرأي الجديدة
أن 71 بالمائة من البريطانيين يعتقدون أن هناك
كان حزباً يضم أغلبية من
الأشخاص الذين صوتوا للمحافظين في
الانتخابات الأخيرة
وربما يكون الأمر الأكثر إثارة للقلق بالنسبة لرئيس
الوزراء هو أن أكثر من ثلثي البريطانيين
يقولون
إنهم يهتمون بما إذا كان
هناك حزب أم لا
وهذا ليس  حتى فضيحة جونسون الوحيدة
، فهو يواجه أيضًا مزاعم
بأنه كذب بشأن التماس أموال من
مانح سياسي لتمويل تجديد
شقته وأنا  في محاولة لمحاربة متغير omicron ،
هناك أيضًا الكثير من
الأسئلة الآن حول ما إذا كان بإمكان رئيس
الوزراء إقناع الجمهور المرهق
باتباع قواعد covid جديدة أكثر صرامة عندما
يبدو أنه لا يستطيع حتى إقناع
موظفيه بفعل نفس الشيء
scott mclean  سي ان ان لندن